parts of canada reach nearly 50 degrees
celsius and high temperatures
have led to hundreds of deaths europe
two is experiencing one of the hottest
summers on record
climate researchers say it's a sign
global warming may have passed a
critical tipping point
living near an outdoor swimming pool
during a heat wave is a fortunate thing
the temperatures soared so high in
alberta canada
that candy melted it's a random event
it's a very
seldom event in observations you don't
see this
over the last 100 or maybe 150 years and
there's no
paleoclimatic evidence from from tree
rings from
other archives that would support that
this has been
experienced in the past such heat may be
a freak event
but what role do human activities on
earth play
in climate change
so the human activities with the release
of
greenhouse gases co2 methane and so on
are leading to a increase of these
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere and
they also prevent that the heat
from from the earth is leaving
the atmosphere so it's collecting
the heat and it leads to a warming
this warming was modeled by scientists
in the u.s
canada and europe for a world weather
attribution report
researchers say hitting nearly 50
degrees in western north america
is virtually impossible without climate
change caused by people
they estimate this global warming made
the heat wave 150 times more likely
this is not a british columbia problem
it's not a canada problem it is a global
challenge and we all need to have
citizens of the world coming together
as we have quite frankly to address a
global pandemic
there is a lot of uncertainty in the
data covering the frequency of heat
waves
as the phenomenon was so extreme but
something the scientific community does
agree on
is that climate change played a big role
for more i'm joined by dw's environment
reporter ajit naranjan
thanks so much for coming in and this is
an unprecedented heat wave in the
pacific north northwest and it was
unrelenting i mean so many deaths nearly
500 heat-related deaths in british
columbia alone
um putting that into perspective uh
that's more than covert for instance in
the same area
is the gravity of this situation sort of
sinking in
yes i mean it completely dispels the
myth that climate change is something
happening in the future for our
grandchildren or something that happens
only far away in kind of poor countries
this is the usa and scientists are
telling us that this devastating heat
wave that we've just seen on our screens
was made a hundred and fifty times more
likely because of climate change
and about two degrees celsius hotter and
that's from
this study published this morning by the
world weather attribution initiative
and what they found were that these
record-breaking temperatures
would have been virtually impossible
without climate change
how are scientists so sure i mean how
they come to this conclusion
so i mean what scientists already knew
and i'm quoting from the report here is
that
every heatwave occurring today is made
more likely and more intense by climate
change
and this is simple physics essentially
like we verif we verify this with other
leading climate scientists
but essentially every time over the last
couple of hundred years when people
mainly enrich countries have burned
fossil fuels they've
released gases that kind of act like a
greenhouse around the earth
and what they do is they trap the heat
from the sun from the sunlight
and they raise the global temperatures
and what this means kind of for natural
weather like weather falls within a
distribution you get cold weather you
get hot weather
but what this does is it shifts the
entire distribution higher
and so what you end up with is that
these extremes at the very top end
you see temperatures like this 49.6
degrees celsius we saw in british
columbia
that just completely blow past well past
what we're used to
and can handle really i mean that's
extraordinarily hot and i'm australian
so
um this may seem like an obvious
question but why is this study such a
big deal
so there's two things really first is
that scientists have gotten much better
at
attributing individual weather events to
global warming to climate change
quickly i mean so within the space of a
week we went from seeing a wildfire wipe
out the village of lytton
in british columbia two scientists being
able to say quantitatively
to what extent climate change affected
the heat wave that kind of drove
drove a lot of this suffering the second
reason which is maybe more important
i mean on that same day that litten
broke its heat what a heat track
temperature record two days before the
wildfire hit hit
another study published in the journal
nature found that
climate lawsuits aren't keeping up with
the latest climate science
and what this means is that we can hold
people accountable
for kind of the damage that we're seeing
much better if scientists can quickly
attribute it quickly and confidently
attribute the extent to which global
warming played a role in an individual
extreme weather event
do you think this study or this weather
event in fact will lead to any real
change
yeah you can already see people waking
up you can see politicians taking notice
and talking about the effects of climate
change much more strongly we know public
awareness around extreme weather events
does change and people's relationship
climate change does change
but to actually make change come out of
this on a meaningful scale
scientists have a whole host of things
that they say would need to happen
to actively combat the effects of global
warming to stop heatwave becoming longer
stronger and more frequent all right
angie thanks very much dw
environment reporter anjeet naranjan i'm
now joined by
dr sharoki philipp she's co-lead of this
study and researcher at the
royal netherlands meteorological
institute
how confident we heard that this is a
freak
event but how confident are you that uh
humanity
has has a hand in this
well it's totally clear that uh without
human induced climate change
this event would have been virtually
impossible
it has been made um at least
a hundred sorry that is me made at least
150 times more likely than it was in the
past and
because it's now even uh really very
extreme
you can imagine that in the past without
climate change it would have been
virtually impossible so although we
don't know all mechanism that played a
role in here and we need to further
investigate that
we do know that climate change does play
a role
well in canada in the past five days
there have been nearly 500
deaths related to the extreme heat
that's more than
from covid in that time do you think the
gravity of what's happening is
slowly sinking in
um yes i think so what the problem is
with cold waves or
flooding the reproductive number of
deaths is often immediately available
and with heat waves they often come in
quite late so
the fact that we already see so many
deaths
from this heatwave is is really amazing
that
that and i'm sure that uh later there
will be
more data available and this number will
go up
but i think this is really a warning and
people are getting more aware of it
talking about data your study predicts
more heat waves
like this in the future and there's a
need to adapt
to that buildings for example can that
be done without
raising carbon emissions even further
uh i think we have to go uh two ways so
we
both have to uh stop or reduce emitting
uh carbon
uh but we also uh have to have another
pathway in which we
just make heat plans and take care of
the people that are vulnerable
it really helps when you have heat
plants and
um for instance just let your neighbor
know that
they should actually drink enough water
to prevent dehydration and also the
cooling center
and more air conditioning that's that's
also uh needed
even if we stop emitting uh carbon
dioxide
so what do the your findings mean for
the rest of the world
well we know now that such a extreme
heat wave can actually occur even with
this
record broken by five degrees so last
year or two years ago we were even
shocked that in the netherlands
record was broken by 1.8 degrees and
this is now 5 degrees
so i think we should take it as a
warning that this extremity
can actually happen already today do you
think this is a
this is the top level i mean we're
hearing about you know nearly 50 degrees
in in canada
can it get worse can it get even hotter
well we have to investigate that we we
just don't know we actually thought
this was not possible but it just
happened so um yeah we still have to
investigate whether this
is just a very unusual event and about
the upper threshold
or that other non-linearities start to
play a role
and we did pass a certain threshold but
that's really uh needs some more time
and
we can't do that uh in in just uh
less than 10 days so that means a couple
of months
before we can give an answer to that dr
shelky phillip
thank you very much for your time